our brand new diatom t-shirt is now up
for pre-order over at microcosmos.store
this shirt was designed by artist Josh
quick and it's a part of our artist
series which also features the recently
restocked tardigrade and Hydra t-shirts
and since it might be a little cold out
there for just a t-shirt we also
restocked the homo sapiens sweatshirt
which I have and wear all the time and
you can find that and the brand new
diatom shirt along with microscopes mugs
and more at microcosmos.store
foreign
[Music]
we don't often get a chance to reference
the rest of the cosmos so we're gonna
seize the moment here while we can when
astronomer Carl Sagan narrated the
series Cosmos he famously said the
following we are away for the universe
to know itself some part of our being
knows this is where we came from we long
to return and we can because the cosmos
is also within us we are made of star
stuff
Sagan was referring to the fact that our
bodies are built out of atoms that are
billions of years old the pieces of
stars that exploded and Scattered into
space eventually settling into the
matter that would form our Earth and
then our bodies
but looking at these ciliates it's
tempting to take Sagan's words more
literally to imagine that the little
twinkles of light are actually stars
that we've dived so deep into the
microcosmos that we have come full
circle and stumbled on the cosmos itself
the place of a telescope though we have
a microscope aimed at a million colorful
constellations enclosed into their own
galaxies and separated by membranes
but it takes more than just a microscope
to see the micro Cosmos lit up like this
James our master of microscopes has used
a tool called a polarizer which
restricts the vibrations of light
traveling towards our samples when this
polarized light hits certain types of
materials the result is what we see here
shiny crystals
and as you might imagine these
intracellular crystals have fascinated
scientists for centuries but the actual
nature of these crystals what they're
made of and what purpose they serve that
has been much murkier if you've been
with us on our journey for a while
you've probably heard us say the phrase
we don't know a lot the microcosmos does
not guarantee answers and we have often
found ourselves looking at some very
unusual behavior or beautiful form that
represents some fascinating unresolved
mystery and this has happened almost
every time we have seen crystals in the
microcosmos we see them we wonder what
they are for and then we move on to say
we don't know but the great thing about
science
is that we don't know is often a
precursor to people finding a way to
learn more
in the summer of 2022 a group of
scientists published a paper in the
international Society for microbial
ecology describing their investigation
into the crystal structures found within
these single-celled eukaryotes they used
a technique called Raman microscopy
which combines a standard microscope
with other tools including a laser to
excite the molecules within a sample in
ways that scientists can effectively
read in plots and graphs that reveal the
identity of those molecules every form
of microscopy is a different way of
seeing the microcosmos and for the
scientists working on this paper Raman
microscopy allowed them to search
through more than 200 species of
eukaryotes and identified the crystals
within them now some of these crystals
were previously known molecules like
calcite and oxalate and carotenoids and
more than 80 percent of the organisms
they studied contained crystals made out
of a type of compound called purines
purines are present in many types of
compounds that are important to life DNA
RNA ATP even caffeine and in the case of
these crystals scientists found purines
appearing in different forms like
guanine and uric acid for algae the
guanine crystals might function as
nitrogen storage helping the organisms
weather the fluctuations in nitrogen
available to them in their environment
but there are also other types of
crystals and other types of organisms
that live in different habitats with
different needs which means there are
likely many other functions that we
still do not know about the ubiquity of
purine crystals suggests that these
types of crystals might be one of the
oldest forms of biocrystallization
present in the last common ancestor to
all eukaryotes so what does this mean
for our organisms well we don't know but
identifying and characterizing these
crystals is just the first step on a
longer Journey one that will reveal more
when we learn how to see what is right
in front of us and the more we learn
about these crystals form and function
in these organisms the more we will
understand about the story of life on
Earth and even about how our own cells
work because these crystals removed as
they are from the original Star stuff
they are made of they still tie the
cosmos and the microcosmos together they
are beacons that do more than simply
Sparkle they illuminate microbes they
show us a way to know ourselves a part
of our being that knows this is where we
came from there is no need to return
because we are already there the
microcosmos is within us but more
importantly we are in the microcosmos
we are made of star stuff that has made
the same stuff life
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us don't forget to go to
microcosmos.store if you'd like to
pre-order our brand new diatom t-shirt
or pick up any of the other microcosmos
products the money from that store goes
right back into this channel so when you
pick up one of those cool Hydra shirts
you can know that you are supporting
what we do here and speaking of
supporting this Channel all the people
whose names are on the screen right now
they are our patreon patrons they're the
people who give a little bit of money
every month and in exchange they get
some cool stuff but mostly I think the
thing that they get is knowing that
they're helping to make this little
project continue to exist uh because of
course without them it definitely could
not if you are interested in joining
them you can check it out at patreon.com
journey to micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
foreign
[Music]